une fois je me suis ensuite passé à la
barge de séance emilie a donné une
vision merci madame la présidente
bonjour à tous monsieur daniel adrian
mais pas lors du derby on n'en a pas
pris ce cas bonne chance monsieur alain
coup de chaud dans les présents
messieurs max delmond je crois qu'il
doit le rejoindre en visioconférence
enfin je ne vous entends pas bien je
suis un petit peu embêté pour j'ai pas
vos retours mal à martin dietrich
attentes
à binh directeur présente monsieur
pascal ferrari
alors voilà pour l'ensemble monsieur
alain grappe
alors madame bernadette gauche disant
monsieur michel habig désordre monsieur
vincent hagenbach présents ont damé miel
dernier présente présente monsieur
nicolas jour d'air est excusé dans une
procuration à madame claire madame
fatima yens ainsi madame brigitte
klinkert madame annick lutenbacher 16
ans monique marcoux non madame josiane
mehlen vettel
lara million raison d'un bébé titulaire
formulaire genre de remarques seront
présents madame fabienne orlandi entre
madame karine pagliarulo sans madame
catherine rap présente les chez marc
chikli
pascale schmidiger et messieurs eric
straumann des pas besoin d'être un
simple crime à y rejouer mais de la
marie france voilà présente youtube par
exemple
merci madame la benjamine car collègues
et messieurs je suis vraiment heureuse
de pour un congrès où la très grande
majorité en présentiel
après plusieurs deux semaines de
réunions et des échanges en anglais
conçu blé et on veut bien tu elle fait
également à produire une eau très
cordiale bienvenue à celles et à ceux de
nos concitoyens qui désirent suivre
notre réunion ce matin henri crohas
reposer grâce aux réseaux sociaux
un bel et bien réunis chaque collègue en
place publique production avant toute
chose je tiens à adresser mes
chaleureuses félicitations à l'ensemble
des maires du département
if our élu à la tête de la commune à la
suite du premier tour des élections
municipales en votre nom à tous je leur
souhaite plein de réussite dans la
conduite de projets et le réjouit d'ores
et déjà de nos prochaines collaborations
les encouragements m'ont tout
particulièrement bien entendu à celles
et ceux d'entre vous qui ont accédé à
cette fonction avec une mention toute
particulière pour pascale schmidiger
pascal hérard y dansait le premier
mandat en tant que premier magistrat
respectivement à saint louis et huila
mes félicitations à l'objet l'ordre du
jour de notre séance seule corde sur des
décisions très attendues
cette série est si sensible aussi sur
deux étapes budgétaire l'incontournable
savoir l'adoption d'une comptabilité et
la fourrière décidée ces rapports
budgétaires nous avons mis un point
d'honneur à les inscrire dans un
calendrier normal de ces termes je tiens
à vous en remercier tout
particulièrement chers collègues ainsi
eu votre direction générale des services
chaque stèle famille sache on est tous
deux par set en sept ans nous avons
davantage dans la gestion de la crise
sanitaire sans précédent
votre pays et plus particulièrement en
alsace l homme de qui
sérieusement vous allez bien terminé
c'est grâce à vous tous chers collègues
lui echard collègues collaborateurs
comme ce que j'appellerais une véritable
révolution démocratique qui nous a
permis de concilier les responsables
religieux nouvel investissement avec
aussi impérative s'ils régler nos
délibérations dans garantissant la
réactivité et la proximité une
efficacité non merci ont chacune et à
chacun d'entre vous dans votre
engagement au service des noises
inaugure un engagement sans faille la
terrible épidémie témoigner il y avait
la peur et la douleur qui ont autant
[Musique]
même si la prudence et la vigilance
d'absolument est admise nous voient
leurs hôtes et les conséquences
économiques et sociales qui résulte de
cette dramatique faisant déjà depuis à
le faire donc les prochains mois
naturellement évident
avant cela je souhaite procéder ce matin
avec vous je reconnais qu'à un premier
bilan de cette crise et en tiraient les
premiers concernés tout premier de ces
enseignements c'est celui de la
pertinence et de la cohérence de
l'échelon hasard dans la gestion au
risque de me répéter je suis persuadé
qu'il a été l'un des principaux garants
de la réactivité et de la proximité et
d'efficacité de l'action du grand ces
dernières semaines d'abord à travers
l'accompagnement et le soutien nous
avons pu apporter aux acteurs de 1ère et
2ème but
saleh tous ceux qui ont porté notre pays
a brillé bras au plus fort de la crise
est au plus haut la bac et puis
on file à travers l'adoption des mesures
un jour je ne rappellerai pas le détail
de nos deux plans territoire actif et
solidaire qui est même l'elysée les
ressources disponibles soutenir les
acteurs économiques et associatifs
engagés de l'activité de plan je vous
propose le compléter aujourd'hui la
création d'un fonds alsacien d'urgence
pour le secteur touristique
doté de près de 5 millions d'euros enfin
à travers la bouche à l'élaboration
d'autres plans qui sont actuellement en
phase de négociation avec de nombreuses
constitueront autant de logis d'actions
supplémentaires pour amortir les effets
de la crise et leur contenu à la relance
de l'économie
si de telles initiatives ont été rendues
possibles châtelet c'est grâce aux
marges de manoeuvre budgétaires que nous
avons su des belges et dans la mise en
oeuvre d'un modèle de gestes il ne cesse
de faire ses preuves par sa rigueur
ainsi que par ceux voulons modèle de
gestion qui au delà de ces vertueux si
elle permet de garantir haute qualité de
service et un fort niveau d'intervention
tout droit alors c'est justement cette
gestion que j'aime bien
intitulé à l'alsacien celle cette
gestion alsacienne dont les effets
bénéfiques sont retranscrites dans le
compte administratif 2010 neuf qui va
être soumis à leur approbation est
illustrée par le rapport d'activité du
service
en voici très très sommairement résumé
des éléments principaux
ce d'impact budgétaire conclu avec lui
en vouloir à 70
17 et encore pleinement respectives
journée tout d'abord le maintien d'une
fiscalité au plus bas depuis cinq ans la
maîtrise de la lettre et de l'eau ainsi
que les charges colis malgré cela et
malgré cela le développement des
investissements manière importante
justice mans opérationnel de répertoire
et le renforcement de politiques
prioritaires notamment en faveur
solidarité jeunesse
les associations et de nos corps est
partout
le deuxième enseignement je souhaite
tirer de la crise syndicales se traduire
cette belle phrase du sociologue edgar
morin nous a rappelé à notre humanité
bien-être condition d'être profondément
sociaux s'est parallèlement dit
puis je suis convaincu que l'épidémie
vous à aider à distinguer la valeur des
vrais chomsky les rapports humains les
liens familiaux la solidarité la santé
mais aussi l'importance de l'innovation
le souci de l'environnement le courage
d'entreprendre le besoin de sucre activé
et cette crise ainsi démontrer la
pertinence de nos priorités celle que
nous mettons en oeuvre depuis le début
une autrement mashako simple de
poursuivre aujourd'hui et que la
collectivité rokia ni d'alsace développe
à son tour des gens qui se sont repris
en main parce que l'humain la femme
banquiers renault d'épanouissement de
chacune et de chacun dans un
environnement préservé les valeurs
alsacienne à la fois naturel et
probablement et à la prise en compte de
ses priorités est encore au centre
vision je veux le rendre à la fois
l'approbation des décisions
modificatives mais aussi par l'adoption
de rapports importants
ensuite près juge bien quelques-uns
l'aide renforcer aux états qui dans la
continuité mais les seniors portes de 11
i à 21000 euros le montant maximal de
subventions accordées par place soit une
économie de 1000 euros par une
amélioration sensible de la qualité de
vie de wouf autre exemple le dispositif
existant l'été
ce dispositif vient compléter les jeunes
nombreuses actions que le mouvement pour
l'action et qui va permettre à nuuk 18,5
en directement impactés par les
conséquences de trouver certaines
activités rémunérées une première
expérience dans des associations des
secteurs moins sensibles
il s'agit d'une démarche citoyenne
gagnant gagnant pour la jeunesse et pour
la société entièrement financé par notre
politique
et puis le troisième et dernier exemple
je souhaite évoquer c'est le nouvel élan
apporté la politique gerland et depuis
exactement d'un an maintenant aussi
tuant des pilules notre stratégie de
protection de cadre de vie et de
développement de l'agriculture locale
des nouvelles orientations
je vous propose d'adopter permettre à
cette politique de s'inscrire dans la
perspective de l'accession de la
collectivité euros merci de répondre
encore nuit au levain environnementaux
de celui-ci et puis le 3e et dani
renseignement il me semble pouvoir tirer
la séquence comme ils disent non c'est
l'importance
fondamental pour l'alsace pour les
alsaciens du développement des relations
avec nos voisins allemands et suisses
oui je dis bien davantage crucial qui
peut même s'avérer vital comme l'ont
démontré les événements tragiques de la
victoire
je crois pouvoir vous dire qu'à ses
enfants d'autres territoires
l'heure n'a jamais autant justifier sa
dénomination de bassin de vie car des
vies il y en avait beaucoup qui ont pu
être préservé voire même sauvé grâce à
l'amitié qui aurait une part et d'autre
du rhin sera un qui justement selon
victor préserver des vies sauvées délit
voilà probablement les plus beau défi
pour tout être humain est sans doute
l'option la plus noble de tout mandat
début je pense chers collègues nous
pouvons être fiers d'avoir contribué en
favorisant la prise en charge de
nombreux patients alsacien dans les
hôpitaux allemands et suisses que je
sais que c'est surtout le sentiment de
devoir nous avons aujourd'hui notamment
à la lecture les mots quand ils ne sont
pas revenus de la part de personnes dans
la ville appuie le domaine de la
coopération transfontalière il faut
aussi tirer albert hâtivement les
enseignements prendra en considération
des enseignements de malice
je rappelle que cette compétence du
transfrontalier sera l'un des piliers
opérationnel et c'est peut être un signe
positif du destin de la réouverture des
frontières tant attendu soit intervenue
le 15 juin soit pile à j moins de sens
la fermeture des frontières avec nos
voisins et amis
parlons-en justement je pensais de
partager mon coin du cher comme elle
cela le 2.8 j'adorais ce produit tout au
fond pas dans ces conditions
et si en alsace mais aussi dans le
paisible adou du côté de bâle à la
frontière est absolument pas vécu et de
la même façon à paris wallah web
car ici la frontière vous le savez tous
ce n'est pas une barrière qu'on peut
décider d'abaisser les jours longue
ce sont des pompes ce sont des milliers
de citoyens doivent emprunter chaque
jour notamment pour des raisons
professionnelles
carmen frontières cela revient donc
entraver gravement et le plan économique
de tout un territoire celui du rhin
supérieur
cela revient aussi à porter un grave
coup à la mine ity les prends vraiment à
l'amitié en caucus et à la construction
car ici c'est d'aller à leur antre du
quotidien partagé celle des citoyens est
sacré entreprises
je me suis donc engagé depuis plusieurs
jours et notamment mercredi devant la
commission europe les affaires
internationales de l'habitacle de bade
wurtemberg qui va auditionner je me suis
engagé dans la promotion chers collègues
d'une preuve d'une gestion commune et
régionaliser les frontières à celle
d'une véritable coopération sanitaire
entre l'alsace et son land voisin et ses
cantons voisins
cette collaboration se traduira
notamment par la mise en place de
projets de recherche d'enseignement
transportable mais elle se concrétisera
surtout par une harmonisation des
pratiques médicales et hospitalières
afin de simples
afin de simplifier les futurs transferts
notation par de la poudre et y compris
en dehors enlevé en 2006 en quarts mieux
se comprendre ses pouvoirs c'est
justement un dossier important de la
coopération transfrontalière que je
souhaite conclure mon propos en amont de
7,6 le savez la presse d'un repris ce
matin
chers collègues nous sommes une dizaine
de jours de l'arrêt du secondaire de la
centrale ce mardi lors de la réunion du
bureau exécutif de notre assemblée le
cil l'air matin devant la mission
d'information parlementaire dans le
suivi de moncler mouture de la centrale
j'ai fortement insisté sur la nécessité
impérieuse de faire ce territoire un
modèle reconversions industrielles
énergétiques au coeur du rhin supérieur
un modèle de reconversion en levant le
doubs les enjeux en termes de retombées
économiques et d'emploi sont essentiels
et les potins une potentialité de cette
zone située à deux pas de l'allemagne et
de la suisse
absolument incontestables notamment par
du projet fait suite à une
reconstruction économique écologique et
d'esprit n'est encore évoquée par le
président de la république lors de son
allocution de dimanche sera un premier
pas important a été franchi
à salalah signature d'ici fin janvier à
colmar fribourg qui va contribuer les
façon essentielle à la lisière de la
lecture aux motifs à présent il est
temps de passer à la vitesse supérieure
du prochain mois
le comble est d'enregistrer des avancées
concrètes porteuse de l'activité
économique et créatif restant plus que
jamais
je le sais mais avec votre
une amie mme charles j'en appelle
d'orgue à l'état de respecter les
engagements qui va être une opération de
six mois ce dossier si importante pour
l'avenir de l'alsace comme dans bien
d'autres je sais droit de faire
confiance à votre ambition partagée
il ya un autre engagement des termes la
gestion de l'épisode 19 encore démontré
la capacité de notre collectivité
départementale s'adapte bien avancé
encore et toujours
albert einstein disait au milieu de tout
prison ce clown grande opportunité
je suis convaincu chers collègues que
nous saurons 16e nouvelle fois ci est
enfermé de grand chose même si je
reconnais le premier vice président à
président de saluer votre département
ce mobilisme en place l'être vraiment
espérer inattendu et surtout venez vite
que nous avons mais grâce à ben bella
c'est grâce à vous madame la présidente
la présidente du département et sai mouk
jamais pris mieux les initiatives qu'il
a fallu prendre moment je salue donc au
nom de mes collègues aussi nous lever et
votre réactivité et votre efficacité la
gestion dans la compétence égale au delà
puisque j'étais un des principaux témoin
de votre engagement et nous votre
investissement pendant 7
j'ai vu le vrai parfois à
l'investissement l'autre par nuitée jour
du mois pendant la période la plus
tendue de la crise avait su prendre les
bonnes décisions et faire en sorte les
nier le nouveau département puisque noël
aux soignants d'une part mais aussi à la
population qui en avaient besoin
je tenais à saluer cet engagement je
crois que le au nom de les voler nous
sommes fiers d'être dans cette
collectivité dans cette assemblée
présidée par vous parce que vous avez su
vous étiez la personne d'ali sabieh osa
même de parfois de nos compétences
réelles pour faire changer les choses et
de pouvoir pousser à ce que les
résolutions
merci pour cela et si nous avons rappelé
au nez des soignants qui l'ont bien
mérité pendant ces périodes de tension
tous les soirs je crois qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez droit au charmant les
applaudissements élu à la présidence
sans humour engagé derrière elle un
soutien d'un accompagnement de tous les
instants je prends
un métier mais aussi et un certain
nombre d'autres demandes de prise de
parole monsieur pierre bihl président de
la jolie terre unis pour le gers il
alors la présidente a menacé dimanche de
chers collègues
voilà enfin nouveau réunis à l'hôtel du
département
cette inhabituelle dès qu'il ya sur
l'essentiel à monsieur pouvoir nous
retrouver au débattre et décider des
mesures à sion le retour à la vie
normale de nos concitoyens nous avons
tous conscience de la brutalité avec
laquelle la crise a vidé les a frappé
notre vie est bien la partie et en
particulier notre le territoire alsacien
nous n'oublions pas non plus combien de
souffrances et la provoc et qu'on garde
la série u dans l'avenir à la fait de
l'être je vous raconte pas les milieux
économiques
nous avons surtout une rechute restera
possible tant qu'un vaccin on va parler
été découverts l'actualité mogale le
démon ou ça l'avait souligné madame la
présidente du cloud vont tout de rester
table et surtout brigitte environ ges et
de profonde et surtout de remercier très
chaleureusement toutes celles et ceux
qui se sont engagés durant dix dernières
semaines pour que notre pays puisse
tenir le choc des ego unis dans le haut
rhin
je voudrais dire combien ce matin c'est
un moment de soulagement qui prédomine
mais aussi un légitime sentiment de
fierté dans les rapports qui sont
présentés lors de cette séance
car il reflète à la fois la rigueur de
notre gestion et la qualité de nos
interventions en faveur de la
responsable relance de l'activité
vous l'avez vous regardez madame la
présidente
c'est parce qu'elle est bien gérée comme
en témoigne d'ailleurs administratif
que notre collectivité a pu apparaître
en première ligne d'abord à la lutte
contre l'épidémie est aujourd'hui dans
le combat au la relance économique
voiture on l'a effectivement les fruits
du travail en profondeur réalisé depuis
2015 dans toutes les commissions et inti
nez dans cette évidence espace cher la
radio à cet égard
trois indicateurs ne semble
particulièrement révélateur de la
qualité de notre gestion à l'alsacienne
et je veux parler du fort niveau de
leurs dépenses en faveur de la stabilité
de nos dépenses réelles de
fonctionnement malgré les augmentations
mécaniques et charges de personnel et
des allocations individuelles de
solidarité et de notre politique active
de désendettement qui importe et
l'encours par habitant de 650 euros
orji gaz à 427 euros en 2019 réduction
très importante mais les japonais que
nous savons faire et même gazelle et
nous ferons au bout pardon mieux lorsque
l'état c'est ça doit la solution a ses
propres problèmes budgétaires car nous
nous tenons nos engagements à son égard
j'avais pour preuve par exemple le
contrat financier qui limite de la
hausse des dépenses de fonctionnement
ado maximale ou sans le fond de rade car
on a beaucoup parlé à plafond que nos
béton par doigt d'honneur à ne pas
attaquer
en revanche la verse des droits ne se
vérifient ainsi les départements
continuer à supporter des dépenses sur
le volume dépend la seule volonté
gouvernementale exemple la politique en
faveur des mineurs non accompagnés
faux le nombre a augmenté de 300% entre
2015 et 2019 ne pouvoir accepter cette
manière purement comptable qui est celle
de l'état quand il prétend dialoguer
avec les collectivités
c'est pourquoi nous continuerons à faire
entendre notre propre voie et à
développer notre propre modèle de
gestion une gestion proche des frères
citoyens et de leurs besoins
une gestion adaptée à nos territoires et
à leur projet l'analyste parfaitement
cette double volonté elle dit en effet
ravir en chiffres le soutien très
conséquent apportée par notre
collectivité
d'abord aux acteurs de la lutte contre
l'épidémie
puis au tissu économique et associatif
s'est durement impactée par la crise
sanitaire ou notre participation au
fonds résistance initié par la région ou
également la création en concertation
avec les homologues parlera d'un four
alsatia en faveur des associations qui
connaît un grand succès nous avons pas
de la création du fonds d'urgence en
faveur du secteur touristique
je vous avais déjà évoqué adam la
présidente lui chers collègues nous
venons de responsabilité car c'est
aujourd'hui et maintenant que se joue
l'avenir de nos entreprises et de notre
association un avenir vide angoissant
joue sur un entre les mains de la
collectivité européenne d'alsace vous
avez totalement raison d'affirmer madame
la paisible la crise sanitaire une
renforcer davantage notre choix en cette
future collectivité d'un litre à la fois
de la rigueur et du volontarisme de la
gestion à l'alsacienne et de notre
détermination à mener des politiques
publiques de continuité innovantes et
performance je vous reçois également
madame la présidente
râpez rieuse nécessité de mettre en
place une coopération sanitaire a les
cheveux bruns supérieur de moi est de
démontrer avec beaucoup de force durant
la pandémie est donc vous voyez donné il
n'y a pas plus de l'honneur que plus
belle l'objectif des élus de le vouloir
contribuer à sauver des vies
[Musique]
à cet égard permettez-moi de la
présidence et a beaucoup au nom de tous
vos collègues de samir autre engagement
personnel de tous les instants pour
cette pilule et tout particulièrement
les veloppement de ses formes inédites
de coopération qui grâce à vous et avec
vous ne viendra probablement à nouveau
pilier la politique transfrontalière la
cellule nous croyez moi désert puisque
jamais on a cas précités d'une opa
territoire à devenir ce territoire
transfrontalier intégré et européen
capable de montrer la voie aux autres
pays de l'union européenne est encore au
sommet de l'état on s'aperçoive aussi
que face à des menaces sans frontières
il faut apporter des réponses rapides et
adaptées et que seuls des collectivités
directement concernés seront apportées
la réactivité et expertise
intema d'urgence nous avons tous entendu
dimanche dernier le président de la
république annoncé une nouvelle
répartition des compétences entre l'état
et les collectivités exprimé sa volonté
je le cite libérer la créativité et
l'énergie de terrain pour donner des
libertés et des responsabilités inédite
à ceux qui agit agissent au plus près de
nos vies et bien chiche monsieur le
président lula connu collectivités
européennes d'alsace soit auckland la
plus laide ou se placent création
madame la présidente chers collègues je
vous remercie pour votre patron sinon
bon votre engagement si fort à nos côtés
est bien vu que l'aca présent la parole
à monsieur philippe intervenir et si
madame la présidente le chercheur est
gratuit
le président de groupe u10 sont absentes
m'a chargé de pensée d'expression
je fais bien volontiers
et pour commencer leur serait un constat
halal est en passe vite
et qu'est ce que la vie a comme une
capacité de reprendre comme si de rien
n'était et je pense qu'il est utile
aujourd'hui comme vous l'avez déjà fait
la présidente de rappeler finalement
dont dieu nous avons trop niveau de
notre région et tout particulièrement
notre département est touché de plein
fouet par une unité d'élite et erin nous
avons passé des semaines difficiles et
douloureuses au l'ensemble des haut
rhinois marquée par un nombre élevé de
décès ce faux pas nous leurrons
traverser les crises sanitaires inédites
et inattendues et cette période a
démontré que nous sommes nous capables
et collectivement réactif et solidaire
[Musique]
aurait un hommage
madame la présidente à l'action que vous
avez mené une action déterminée mais
dont la force tient aussi et avant tout
à la cohésion de notre assemblée a voté
et donc j'en profite pour adresser un
hommage à tous de nos collègues qui se
sont également invités dans la gestion
de cette crise
aujourd'hui nous bénéficions d'un
ralentissement de la propagation du
virus ce qui nous permet d'être
prudemment optimistes en veillant à
respecter les mesures grâce auxquelles
cette épidémie restera sous contrôle
mais l'épidémie n'est pas terminée on
sait la crise sanitaire a laissé place à
une crise économique et sociale auquel
il va falloir faire face aux répondre à
une crise bien sûr il faut prendre les
mesures vous permet de la passer en
minimisant ses conséquences négatives
mais c'est aussi en tirer des leçons
pour renforcer les territoires et faire
en sorte qu'ils en sortent plus fort
qu'avant la craie ne doivent plus être
comme avant
voilà le fait qu'il doit nous river on
le disait en pleine crise sanitaire
on l'entend - aujourd'hui et la vie
ayant repris son cours pour répondre à
la crise économique il convient
effectivement de répondre à l'urgence et
le genre pour les entreprises c'est de
disposer d'une trésorerie elles ont
continué leurs activités
pour cela des fonds d'urgence sont mis
en place le tourisme pèse un poids
important dans l'économie de notre
territoire
c'est pourquoi nous devons soutenir ces
acteurs en répondant à la spécificité de
leurs besoins au delà du fonds de
soutien des entreprises mis en place par
l'état et la région
nous nous félicitons par conséquent du
fonds d'urgence exceptionnelle que nous
avons voté aujourd'hui en faveur de la
filière touristique
de même nous nous félicitons de la mise
en place d'un fonds de danse
départemental destiné à soutenir des
associations tant les acteurs
associatifs participe activement à
l'animation et à la vie de notre
territoire mais il y a une leçon
primordial que nous devons tirer de la
crise sanitaire
c'est l'importance fondamentale de la
preuve
l'idée qui seule permet une véritable
réactivité et les licenciant en parfaite
adéquation avec les besoins réels du
territoire c'est pourquoi au-delà du
respect de ses engagements que nous
vraiment non effectivement aller taille
nous nous associons à cette demande à la
présidente
au-delà de ça les états doivent être en
mesure de faire plus car là le fus nous
tirons de ce que nous avons vécu c'est
que nous devons demander une relance de
la décentralisation de sorte que les
bonnes compétences soient exercées sur
les banques
perrinelle le daily mail pertinence ou
de nombreux sujets s'avère pour nous
être alsacien
posez-la du département parfois sous
dimensionné mais on de sable la région
trop éloignées en insistant également
sur les liens forts qui nous constitue
avec le nos voisins transfrontalier
c'est pourquoi agit moins deux cents 200
jours la création des collectivités
européennes d'alsace je pense qu'on va
retenir que la leçon de la crise que
nous venons passé et de sa gestion
c'est le bien fondé de la connectivité
européenne d'alsace mais aussi le besoin
qu'il y aura dans confettis des
compétences notamment dans le domaine
économique et pour les moins de 7 et
mentalités avec la région c'est ce que
l'on est en droit de revendiquer et cela
tient non seulement aux besoins de
décentralisation mais également un
besoin de différenciation dans la mesure
où il convient aussi de tenir compte de
la spécificité de notre territoire
alsace et la crise sanitaire économique
et social
donc si nous amener à aborder
budgétaire de manière innovante
la première innovation et erbil lundi
des consistera con et tu as à faire
confiance aux collectivités locales en
leur adressant une belle elsa de marge
de manoeuvre et en relâchant les
contraintes de la contractualisation des
besoins liés à la crise sociale qui
arrive le rendront toute façon
incontournable
la deuxième innovation sera plus un
thème dans le cadre d'une évolution du
périmètre fiscal de financement de nos
collectivités
car obscur budget devront faire face à
des besoins de fonctionnement plus
important nous avons pour accompagner
les plus fragiles et les fragiliser du
fait de cette crise mais aussi des
besoins d'investissements aussi
importants dont la réalisation devra
être accélérée
de sorte que notre collectivité
participe pleinement à la relance de
l'activité
d'autant plus que la crise sanitaire a
dégradé l'attractivité de notre
territoire
c'est injuste mais c'est un fait
laquelle attractivité et donc à
reconquérir
c'est donc une action en profondeur
qu'il durera tu vas falloir engager est
financé à l'échelle de l'alsace dans
cette perspective on peut dire que la
création de la collectivité urbaine
d'arras tombe à pic
c'est la bonne réponse aux besoins d'un
bel immeuble depuis l'iss et nous avons
à passer en priant bien à ce que notre
territoire en sortent renforcées
à nous donc de faire en sorte que cela
serve à donner un grand avenir à notre
territoire à l'alsace est de faire en
sorte que la gestion de crise actuelle
en soin de lui merci
et je retiens c'est le mot confiance
confiance à la proximité confiance aux
élus locaux confiance à des élus locaux
qui savent prendre leurs responsabilités
combien les était à nous aussi conseillé
les parties permis dans la gestion de la
crise est bien s'en sortir de sortie
madame fatima yen est la star de mes
collègues je voudrais aider son collègue
cas vous êtes informés pendant cette
fuite sur le mode du moment de traverser
et malheureusement pas terminé a su à
lire avec arme acquise mais je l'aï fait
car j'étais au service haut-rhinois et
de leur sens
j'adresse tous les convives en les plus
à leur présidente brigitte un carton qui
a mis toute son énergie dans cette
solidarité active qu'elle a su mener
avec rapidité et responsabilité ainsi je
suis fier aussi de dire que notre
commission la vienne dans l'ordre de mes
progrès a été la première de l'action
remercie les services les professionnels
des conseils départementale qui ont été
présents tout le temps malgré nos
confidences je ne vais pas énumérer tous
au pjak déchets mais le renoir doivent
aujourd'hui savoir le plus précisément
possible toutes les actions menées pour
répondre à leurs besoins dans l'urgence
et kumho contre lyon demain dans la
résilience dit mme rosine de vous
présenter ainsi en quelques mots
l'opération de répéter que la présidente
avait présenté ce pas la langue en plage
pour le jour à l'avenir puisque nous
rentrons maintenant dans l'été et
recevant qui sera là pour notre jeunesse
vous savez comme président allemand le
département embaucher des jeunes pour
les actions et imac s'embêter une
centaine d'années nous confions aux
associations cette mission elles
viennent aussi bien échelon de
l'association de l'aide alimentaire et
de l'éducation à l'environnement
soixante cinq jeunes ont d'ores et déjà
que candidat ils vont être recrutés nous
allons aussi mauvaise distribution de
masques pour l'établissement de la
protection de l'enfance pour ibex merci
à l'association sainte sous qu'il a fait
don de ligne basque nous allons forcer
les hits et personnels soignants et des
adjoints techniques dans le delta nous
avons été très actifs ces derniers mois
et le continueront à l'être pour l'aide
à la parentalité l'accompagnement des
parents
nous donnons des regrets pour les
personnes âgées pour lutter contre leur
isolement
le champion les volontaires par des bons
d'achat
nous adaptons nos pratiques aux
contraintes de licencier sion sociale
nous accordons particulière à
l'initiation
car la question de l'environnement est
essentiel que je n'hésitais que cela
mais on a fait énormément
alors merci encore madame la présidente
merci avant tout et tout richard tél il
m'a dit merci d'abord nous absenter
chine sur le travail exemplaire à dire
extraordinaire de notre en direction de
la solide mais aussi de lancer le
premier vice président a dit à l'heure
sur lui je sais que merci il n'y a pas
d'autre je regarde les demandes de
parents le préalable
toujours et ce à la presse m
madame r vous avez la production votre
action à 13 ans est le premier joueur
réactivité le fait d'avoir lancer très
rapidement
le plan d'urgence l'envoi mot citoyen
pour les associations pour les
entreprises
cette personne a notamment évoqué aussi
la présence humaine dans la pression
psychologique
ce soit pour les élections cantonales
comme pour d'autres personnes et je
voulais droit vous en remerçie personnel
infirmier en introduction j'ai entendu
que bien entendu nous aurons besoin
financier ce soit en fonctionnement le
reste y semant mais nous savions d'ores
et déjà sans en avoir réellement
conscience bien sûr la crise que
personne ne pouvait nous avions d'ores
et déjà il ya quelques années vivions à
traverser ce mouvement plus important
que ce soit au niveau social
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça et j'en
remercie bien sûr voilà président
clinton l administration que nous avons
faits très près qu'ici on va dire a déjà
faire ces économies et nous avons
aujourd'hui un autre financement sans
précédent je vous en parlais tout à
l'heure nous allons réduire
l'endettement votre notre objectivité et
depuis plus de cinq ans et c'est ce qui
nous donne aujourd'hui la possibilité
bien de pouvoir répondre aux urgences et
2.4 et aux enjeux qui nous avons par
rapport à la crise économique et la
crise sociale est toujours but bien
présent sur le premier rapport aux
affaires présentées il s'agit de la
commune iv
gestion pea alors justement la gestion
de la dette nous sommes passés en 1404
car indivision tant d'aisance à 325
millions d'endettement
c'est d'un désengagement sans-précédent
bien entendu aujourd'hui la capacité de
désendettement
le conseil départemental est exemplaire
nous sommes à 3,2 années alors que nous
étions à 6,9 année en 2014 suffit nous
donne la possibilité et bien de pouvoir
investir
c'est ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure de
pouvoir investir et nous avons très
important il a même réussi à diminuer
cet endettement entre 2,18 et le visage
parce que nous avons dîné avec 2,21 à
katyn
entre ces deux exercices donc la
structure est ce qu'elle veut elle
répartit entre 58% de 2 42% de tout en
affichant un taux moyen de 3 est le cas
je mets le reçoit par voie autre
s'abstient rapport adopté mercy et nous
pouvons passer entendre suivant sinon
message il les compte rendus des
délégations crise par vous même par la
présidente en matière de subvention est
de 40
rappelons que si la méditation
s'insultant le calvez lors de leurs deux
premières années 2020 visant à assurer
la continuité du fonctionnement des
institutions le 4 on en a créé d'une
commune c'est à dire fois dans le groupe
a c'est au salon ont fait département
pas l'oublier ou même octroyé des
subventions est octroyée en lien directe
des garanties d'emprunt mais bien
entendu cela doit être sue par la suite
à ce conseil c'est plus de 2 millions
d'euros la présence en termes de
subventions et celui des 15 millions en
termes de garantie d'emprunt qu'on sait
c'est l'importance de ces montants alors
c'est important d'un montant de
garanties d'emprunt par ce à partir du
moment où garantissons des emprunts et
bien les taux aussi bancaires peuvent
être plus humble plus intéressant
personnes qui demandent maison mais cela
vous et c'est vrai que grâce aux
possibilités qu il n a été donnée
d'accord les subventions s'affermit à
vocation de rester à flot par des petits
est ce qu'il ya des questions 900 cas je
leur envoie qui les autres qui
s'abstient un rapport adopté
je vous remercie cette réforme le le
congrès gestion de vous savez que d'oeil
à voir évidemment ni l'audition tour de
gestion qui a réalisé par le comptable
public et les comptes administratifs qui
a réalisé par me mène d'un donateur en
termes de finances ce compte de gestion
2009 doit être approuvée quant aux
condamnés ça veut dire que justin me
tend aujourd'hui à mon cadet 28 398
euros et 34 100 qui correspond à une
écriture qu'il faut encore régularisé
sur le budget principal le titre de la
reprise il sonne d'investissement de
lagence des festivals de musique à sa
dissolution à ormes dit ça tout cas un
total commenté la président merci à vous
va pas de main se lève et je voulais
donc le rapport on voit automne quand
abstention d'un rapport est à noter
qu'une passe à présent la parole pour
présenter le compte administratif 2010
voilà le condamner hâtivement
on va fois les mémoires
mystique autochtone qui c'est un
résultat très intéressant de ce compte
administratif une terre où il explique à
vichy tout d'abord les dépensiers le
fonctionnement s'est élevé à 575 mm50 de
10 ans en documentation de 2,18
président qu'il chers collègues et
s'explique notamment par la volonté de
renforcer notre action auprès des
populations les plus fragiles
nous avons été humiliés pendant social
et de 3 millions pour la politique d'
inception et 3 5 millions pour la
comédie case oui nous avons filmé -
millions une augmentation d'un film en
observant un coup de péréquation tout ce
ballon de pouvoir m'expliquer suivant
donc vous voyez cette répartition
concernant l'assaut 3 c'est quand même
plus de 65 % de notre budget total
évidemment notre conquête en cours
concernant justement cette répartition
vous a appelé la solidarité avec
inception qui constitue certainement la
mélodie qui permette vieux de promouvoir
bien qu'ils rassemblent dans notre
société et donc le département a
consacré 106 à cette politique en 2019
soit plus de 3 millions d'euros par
rapport à mai 2008
donc il faut quand même rappeler ces
deux contrôles josiane à toi tu sur les
actions qui ont été menées
tout d'abord dispositif rsa révolat qui
a permis d'établir à 272
contrat d'engagement réciproque espace
social le 31 décembre 2019 et puis
également le département s'est fortement
impliqué en faveur de l'emploi des
bénéficiaires renforcer les entreprises
comme une victoire à sion qui grâce à
plusieurs départements les contraintes
qui voilà pour cette insertion
conservant une personne en situation
d'handicap un montant de 102 et
bienvenue de droit une augmentation
comme dirait le devoir légère
augmentation de cultiver vendu à plus de
50 groupes pour la pch alors sur la
solidarité a toujours chanté en france
pour un montant de 89,8 euros au
département et à s'attacher à lui
amélioré et de sa politique de
protection notamment à travers la mise
en droits commerciaux neil de la
reconfiguration de l'offre son
déplacement a permis de déployer de
nouvelles classes d'accueil séquentielle
web visible via un service
d'accompagnement éducatif à 12h06
renforcée ensuite je ne vais pas ne pas
voir justin pour les personnes âgées
soixante deux roues et bien entendu pour
renforcer beaucoup mieux de nenê ou la
favoriser
c'est 3,5 inonderont succulent vert par
rapport à 18
je rappelle aussi un appel à projets
spécifique dans l'hôpital a également
fait et c'était pour hérésie pour un
monde dans leur totalité des 300 euros
les vingt six résidences ou de loups du
congrès ont perçu un montant de 500
euros pour proposer des actions de
prénoms jouent alors résident
concernant les actions éducatives pour
un montant de 14 ans arrivant vous voyez
la répartition est un cliché c'est neuf
camions pour l'écologie et 4,7 sur les
routes et vous soit en fonctionnement
comment l'investissement clairement une
département largement développé
documents et les progressions des
dépenses d'entretien courant de la
chaussée et puis le dialogue s'est tenue
les 12 fauchage des accotements du 2-0
gamme donc sur les ressources humaines
j'en profite toujours à l'inter on doit
remonter montrer d'accès ces montants
j'en profite et les tournois jonny lang
mes collègues aussi de remercier
l'ensemble du personnel pour tous de
travail n'a rien d'écrit j'en profite
pour parler de la direction des finances
si des gestes remercie bien entendu leur
histoire et la chance d'avoir un
directeur qui est le directeur des
finances du haut-rhin et du bas-rhin ça
préfigure très positif pour la
collectivité européenne menace parce que
nous aussi nous travaillons d'ores et
déjà en exploitant complémentarité sur
les finances du haut-rhin et du bas-rhin
voir commencer c'est une création de la
collectivité en plaine d'alsace donc sur
le constat de 1280 13 agents 31 décembre
2009 où c'est un bandit 96,7 donc sur
mon service départemental d'inscription
secours c'est +0 26% marcheprime ou
aussi on travaille de plus en plus
difficile en tant que aussi vice
présidente delphine en feu dix 10 ans ou
tous et surtout après cette période de
commander tout au long de l'année ils
ont réalisé un travail très très
remarquable et je pense qu'on félicite
et je rappelle quand même que nous nous
disent le département finance à 50% le
budget total de 6 et une collectivité
c'est à dire comme unis les conseillers
ont en charge les autres voilà comment
la section de fonctionnement en dépenses
sur la section de fonctionnement en
recettes
il y avoue le constater il ya un
effectif de diminution des recettes de
fonctionnement c'est-à-dire un mois 0,3
cm est celle du show correspond à la
division des droits de mutation par
rapport à 2008 2 buts est évidemment
très façon à dire l'endroit notation
avions obtenu 110 euros mois de tension
nous l'avions déjà prévus au budget
qu'il ne reste qu'une solution
cette diminution est bien réel parce que
nous avons en 96 euros de droits de
mutation que vous avez d'ailleurs ici et
bien l'explication est l'augmentation ou
la diminution des années mais nous
sommes toujours très prudent lorsqu'on
réalise en budget c'est à dire quasiment
en 2020 pour le budget 2010 nous avons
intégré un montant de droit de m
de 90 minutes de route heureusement
parce que on fatigue ou trois premiers
mois ont été très intéressants
augmentation de cas qui vient vivre
tranquillement prévoir comment dirais-je
ou prévoir de façon cherche les mots les
[Musique]
prud'hommes alors concernant la taxe
foncière sur la taxe foncière vous savez
que depuis quatre ans est bien éloigné
des doutes de système damien vitaux de
13,7 pour cent
le tout bas du grand est avec les bas
rhin et là des plus faibles de france
il a bien dit et on entend aujourd'hui
souvent certaines personnes dire ah les
promesses pour les entendais est-ce que
doux mais réaliser réellement et bien
d'autres
vous avez fait connaître au début
maintenant 1 2 pénalités
le cube à ne pas les augmenter ce taux
de fiscalité depuis quatre ans comme
vous tous le devoir il y a dix thèmes
dotation globale de fonctionnement les
bars contre la contribution sur la
valeur ajoutée des entreprises est en
forte augmentation
ce qui montre est quand même à dynamisme
et quand même de notre territoire
victoire je rappelle quand même que
taïwan dimanche 2020 prévoit de
transférer des deux indiens taxe
foncière propriétés bâties communal en
échange d'une fraction de pda et nous
devons évidemment j'ai cela ou tout près
pour vérifier que nos finances c'est
bien pour hauteur de ce que nous
attendons par rapport à la hauteur des
dépenses suivantes salon qui vont suivre
alors il a été dit par fierville avons
un side à cette affaire pour 2009 la
contractualisation avec l'état et bien
était pour un montant de 563 demandait
au maximum de dépenses et 563 euros de
dépenses de fonctionnement rapport à
s'implanter hors les plantes
contractualisation avec les coins il y
en a encore nous avons été exemplaires
parce que nous avons réalisés en termes
de dépenses de fonctionnement un montant
total de 555 cette route bien manque
d'eau en deçà du plafond euros en mousse
voilà malgré tout cela pour dire que
nous avons une gestion très saine on
peut le dire comme temps en temps se
faire un plaisir mais c'est très serré
c'est la réalité
c'est véritablement aujourd'hui nous
allons pas passifs financement qu'il
nous permet de pouvoir l'être présente
pendant cette crise est devant la crise
économique et sociale qui nous attend
nous avons un autofinancement de 103,6
millions d'euros en 2010 il a pas de
financement en 2015 de 68,8 me donc un
véritablement un tour et parle à 15 1 3%
il faut savoir que la moyenne nationale
de la présidence bush tour sans que la
zone d'averses est entre 8 et 10% que
vous plaire nous avons vraiment une
situation très simple et je pense
vraiment viable et d'avoir une vie
décente avec six ans par ce document
nous permet bien entendu de pouvoir
investir de fer et de lui les empreintes
ou alors d'avoir plus d'investisseurs
nantes indépendant investissons vous
avez sur le slide les dépenses
d'investissement pas politique
il faut dire c'est que l'investissement
en opérationnel c'est plus de 100 ml
réellement réalisé en deux vous vous
avions réalisé en 2002 eu 83 millions
d'euros
et c'est aussi important en terme
d'économie développement le comique et
vos entreprises bien entendu parce plus
nous avait dit qu'on sait très bien
l'investissement l'a réalisée en grande
partie par les collectivités
mais en plus aux investissements sont
plus et bien les entreprises à nos côtés
sont satisfaites ils peuvent développer
aussi leur chiffre d'affaires donc nous
allons réaliser le résultat opérationnel
plus de son on aime bien vous montrer
quelques photos mais expliquer donner
quelques exemples d'opérations
d'investissement concernant les réseaux
et amusante culture dans cinq ans une
gageure par numéro
la réparation dimension la flèche
sénégal saed d'un mois à walheim voilà
la discipline sur la construction
d'ouvragés d'art parle jamais assez mais
il faut savoir que c'est une des
compétences on va peut-être pas aidé en
importance du conseil départemental a
ensuite nous avons au 31 décembre
l'aviation de ballad of training et nous
avons également les travaux de
renforcement sur la rd représentants
quand un homme très seul sur
l'aménagement un environnement là aussi
l'illustration pour la politique
concernant l'enseignement je vous
rappelle aussi
nous avons un plan pluriannuel
d'investissements conséquents sur la
restructuration rénovation collège
vauban 19,3 les exemples de wintzenheim
de saint-amarin vous avez à l'écran et
la culture du sport c'est à dire 3 50
euros consacrés à leur politique serait
de 0,5 million d'euros consacrés à la
politique du sport et 1,8 milliard
d'euros consacré à la politique jeunesse
sur le développement économique devront
bien entendu qui la démange mentalement
plus difficile que j'ai l'impression et
les poursuivant notre soutien aux quatre
syndicats mixtes gestionnaires de
stations de haute montagne
voilà sur les explications de de
fonctionnement et de l'investissement et
comme je vous ai déjà dit je leur ai
bien désendettement du département qui
nous permet aujourd'hui bien des
gobelets notre investissement dans les
futures années slip légitimise dans la
collectivité européenne d'alsace ces
nouvelles compétences que nous sur les
recettes dont l'investissement
eh bien vous avez vous tenté par 41 20e
droit
donc on a quand même dû parle de
milwaukee l'ont toujours par rapport à
l'exercice en 2010 et vous avez
l'explication je ne sais pas s'il vous
plaît et c'est la présentation par
chapitre compte administratif le nôtre
l'arrêt notamment vous remet ses clauses
mentation réalise fonctionnement demain
il est toutes les explications tout à
l'heure
tu veux dire un hommage à quoi ressemble
un compte administratif en chiffres et
par xavi ce qui est intéressant de le
savoir
c'est à ce compte administratif est un
bon résultat
les comptes administratifs par le regard
aux états de compte à nos fatigues nous
avons un résultat excédentaire de 82,2
d'eau donc avec ce résultat excédentaire
90 tout de suite dans un palace une
décision modificative
mais ce résultat excellent tabou 80 des
résultats excellents résultats positifs
excédentaire parce qu'on va revoir
l'organisation de 46,16 fonctionnement
est de 35,5 excédent d'investissement et
je vous proposerai tout à l'heure leur
affectation
ballard la production merci exemple
illustratif démontre en effet que nous
avons une assise budgétaire saine et des
sels fondamentale tout particulièrement
comme dylan il souligné dans le texte
crée du corps des virus et la mise en
oeuvre de revanche sociale
mais merci à vous pour votre grand
banditisme en italie la commission elle
associe la direction là le débat est
ouvert
on vous
pour les 10 ou simplement faire quelques
remarques à la suite de cette
présentation
alors j'avais déjà fait cette remarque
quelques années moi je suis toujours
inscrit par les présentations du jet
elle est purement g d'herbe ou à celle
des millions mais en même temps la
possibilité d'en mesurer l'efficacité et
en particulier la libye maintenant quand
même par rapport aux dépenses de
fonctionnement consacrer la politique
sociale de voir s'il manquait le levier
que constitue ses dépenses c'est à dire
la question des résultats possibles de
ces bolides le ainsi financé on consomme
100 millions d'euros consacrés à la
section ses larmes
mais pour quel résultat et par rapport
aux autres départements constitue
comment je ne veux pas qu'on soit jaune
mais en même temps ça va mieux
en démontrant que moi j'appelle de mes
voeux
je parlais tout à l'heure d'une
innovation le budgétaire 4 la
collectivité de l'européenne alsace
c'est d'avoir une gestion budgétaire au
moins un handicap à sa représentation
qu'ils soient eux comme évaluation de
son efficacité de son de son résultat
ensuite bon moi je t'assure à tous sur
internet dans la gestion du budget pour
nous
résultat qui était présente et je prends
bonne note
nous sommes de bons élèves que nous
avons réussi à diminuer de moitié
notre capacité à augmenter notre
capacité de désendettement va déplacer
de 6 ans à trois ans mais je me dis ah
soir à 1
pour quoi faire six ans et caravanes six
ans c'est un bon résultat
mon père est de trois ans et deux fois
mieux
oui et puis un an et demi ça va être
encore eu lieu et puis 0 l'as et c'est
parfait mais est ce que c'est ça
l'objectif
et pourquoi je dis ça c'est pas c'est
pas simplement de style c'est parce que
je m'appelle est quand même dans la boue
on en a parlé tout à l'heure la voir
qu'on va avoir une crise économique et
sociale qui va être important elle va
être massive il va falloir que nous
mettions les moyens nécessaires vous
avez dit faire face et en particulier
contribuer à la relance de l'activité et
donc je me demande qui aurait amené à
devoir changer de mutuelle de paradigme
alors déjà concernant les marges de
manoeuvre alors j'ai lu qu'il ya un
excédent de fonctionnement mais
néanmoins des bennes constater qu'en
termes de tendance
il ya une augmentation des dépenses de
fonctionnement est pareillement une
diminution des recettes de
fonctionnement
donc je dis en 2019 on est déjà dans
cette tendance
attention 2004 ne sera pas du tout même
à 2019 et 2021 et 2022 des contrées
alors on se réjouit d'avoir une capacité
d'autofinancement brocante à la suite de
ce que je viens
je m'interroge sur la future capacité
d'autofinancement alors bon on va se
situer contient 2020 essentiellement
rectification apportée la cia mais la
question
nous allons nous inscrire dans une
récente financement notre collectivité
on aura encore moi le nucléaire il faut
des marges de manoeuvre pour tout ça
pour dire que le fait national a
collecté européenne nasa devra
s'accompagner d'une évolution notre
modèle qui puisse être adapté et plus
adapté aux contraintes du présent et de
l'avenir je pense que c'est c'est un
constat
on doit faire donc on peut se déjouer de
ce que l'on a réalisé aujourd'hui il
faut avoir conscience qu'il va falloir
être capable d'évoluer
bien sûr je voulais juste rappeler que
la compétence insertion et ses
compétences obligatoires des
départements premièrement et le public
concerné c'est public el béchir des reds
a donc déjà dans le métier que vient de
présenter l'exposition il ya intègre un
temps que les rixes à danser ça veut
dire que ça se sont rendus directement
assumé par rapport à l'exercice en tout
court je veux dire de ce public
on est énormément volonté et
d'innovations pour répondre à ceux qui
t'ont l'emploi lui l'emploi limité parce
que c'est pas évident dans le film x-men
sagna très fragile très isolée l'ex
femme anna
donc l'insertion et encore plus de
moyens et de passion mais aujourd'hui je
ne peux rentrer dans la légende comme
jadis d'endettement l'insertion ou vous
dire que nous avons du retard par
rapport au public qu'on doit le cv est
avec nous avons beaucoup aussi chercher
des partenaires par exemple l'insertion
par le sport
l'accession par d'autres moyens que nous
finançons et en faisant très attention à
l'obtention aucun mouvement de supporte
pas
concernant ce domaine il a besoin merci
j'ai un collègue monsieur quelque chose
monsieur tribales le président et madame
l action la présente le soulignait fait
que accord qui nous est présentée montre
que depuis une seconde à soulac options
de votre prédécesseur et l' autre hacker
doit d'avoir une grande rigueur
budgétaire nous sommes désengagés de ce
que nous considérions pas comme en
compétences fondamentales
ça a été parfois douloureux ma voisine
en sait quelque chose
je pense qu'à un moment donné sur ces
sur nos compétences fondamentales bras
se reposer la question des efforts que
nous sollicitons près de mon partenaire
d endettement ne me semble pas une fin
en soi et comme les philippe si je
travaille a demandé mais il faudra que
nous puissions notamment vis-à-vis des
stations partenaires avant fortement
sollicités avoir la capacité
soit ordonnée du g autres expressions
géraud négocier rien j'ai une question
de compréhension à la page 4 du rapport
entre les sorties exercices négatifs
présentation si je reconnais ma deuxième
saison
merci madame la présidente je vois
subjectivement voler comme un jeu je
crois que eux ils ont assez sur
l'analyse de la création d'emplois qui
devraient dégager le domaine de
l'insertion la mienne est que nous avons
misé a lourdement et très fortement sur
juste droit de rater financière
d'allocations entre autres le réalisera
lé aussi de l'aide au retour à l'emploi
tracé culturel essentiel lorsque très
souvent devait souligner la solidarité
vous économiques et sur le passe temps
aussi de montrer que nous sommes
responsables
l'utilisation d'une autre vaisseau mais
également le tout les épaules nombreux
très très précis pour contraindre les
gens à l'emploi pour les accompagner au
niveau à soutien
et les psychologies permettre aux gens
de retrouver de la dynamique de la
cuisine pour pouvoir prétendre à l'intro
leur père est mon cas des revenus et je
crois que la cochrane ont soulevé des
angles a vraiment les efforts qui ont
été faits et par les collègues qui sont
présents en permanence au plus près
quand même le souligner avec des
adaptations et des ajustements bleus le
choc seconde ou être dans une dynamique
je le choix de plusieurs voyageurs déjà
rappelé quand on pense aux vendangeurs
les faits qui a été là dans un schéma
hiver positif et de nos allocataires du
rsa fonctionnement ld et à porter le
voile de leur sortir de manière pérenne
et là je crois qu'il ya vraiment eu un
côté des économies financières de papa
mais également une réinjection de
l'énergie et les moyens et des vraiment
au quotidien nos concitoyens et d'être
réactive sur toute situation sur
laquelle nous pouvons l'être être en
fonction
on l'avait au niveau de l'insertion
on l'a près au niveau de l'aide aux
personnes âgées aux personnes
handicapées donc vraiment ces cellules
âgées ont été systématiquement
réinjecter est accompagné dans cette
notion là est censé être la cantinière
elles ont quand même du problème c'est
comme ça a été le cas de madame la
présidente au roman de cette crise nous
avons su montrer beaucoup de réactions
49e et voilà qu'on peut être là tout de
suite je pense était fait et j'espère il
est considéré comme bien réagi ce fait
partie c'est intéressant
moi je suis quand même surpris parce que
je parlais d'annulation et on veut
répondre principe les sentiments
principes eux
enfin si prochain à faire du mieux qu'on
peut oui mais je n'ai jamais douté je
m'inscris dans ce délai aucun problème
et sentiments des sentiments de ton
d'être efficace j'ai aussi ce sentiment
là mais qu'est ce qu'on ferait le
mesurer je ne présente pas comme une
critique aperçoit malentendu c'est
certainement une proposition pour
améliorer les choses et quand on
présente un budget il me semble qu'ils
seraient intéressants la notion qu'on
présente un budget intéressant au même
essayé une décoration
il nous permet d'en mesurer l'efficacité
prouvée et de se comparer aux autres
et s'il s'avère en mesure en aimant
remarque qu'on est meilleurs qu'eux
raison qu'on est bon et c est bien
parfait et je pense que c'est clair a
également noué l'ombre aux citoyens
voilà donc mené surtout qu'il y ait pas
de malentendu sur les intentions de
l'intervention merci merci madame la
présidente
on a toujours des origines
je pense sincèrement à le trouver
je ne partage pas là pour la défendre
je vous rappelle effectivement volé dans
un compte administratif c'est la faute
aux marques à c est qu on n'est pas dans
du budgétaire
moi je le félicite à l'éthique que j'ai
donné que je suis parisienne là c'est à
dire que l'état malien
lorsqu'on en a besoin regardez ce qui se
passe en allemagne lalanne a bien dû
soutenir ses entreprises avec le démon
grands gains importants à ce qu'ils
avaient gestion saine
lorsque les finances se portent garants
donc c'est bien on va maintenant entrer
dans une situation difficile et aider
des richesses baisse de 11% cette année
et moi je suis on me montrait de
redonner à manhattan pour faire face à
ses échéances qui vont être difficiles
et là je partage leur communion et de
critiques ont pas bon je compris le sens
du débat
enfin heureusement on a ce matin que les
jaune et noir puissent traverser l'île
dans les meilleures conditions
et puis le franchement entre nous les
nutons au débat à l'échelle
départementale
c'est déjà suffisamment compliqué à
l'échelle municipale
mais j'ai toujours jeu j'accepte toutes
les observations et ses cars dont l'un
d'eux merci cher que l'allemagne ou
merci merci d'abord j'aimerais quand
même rappeler à mushaki quand on voit on
pas faire la différence entre un budget
qui est prévisions et qu'on a déjà voté
pour 2020 et l'on compte administratif
c'est la photo de
analyse et exécutées en 2010 elle est
aujourd'hui nous avons sept photographes
ça c'est le premier au point que je
voulais dire cher eric locale par son
sens bien dans mon cas 20h58 autant sur
l'utilité vif et vous savez dans la vie
quand on a eu très pragmatique
ou est-ce que pyogenes et j'aimerais
bien qu'on me dit que ce soit conseil
départemental mamadou koné dit une
chanson on fait partie des mêmes
familles des touches ensemble c'est à
dire qu'il faut conseil départemental
voilà ma ration on n'est pas loin des
auditions objets très bien effectivement
les questions municipal spécial ce que
tu viens en fait et bienheureux gêne pas
trop que ce soit qu'il que ce soit l'un
on a toujours l'impression des cas les
journalistes qui dit qu'en fait le plein
on le fait ensemble une porte ensemble
on a décidé ensemble de se défendre
c'est parce que justement sa belle et ça
fait cinq ans que je dis bien sûr
soutenu par les présidents successifs
qu'on sait qu'on va avoir des preuves de
fiscalité qu'on sait qu'on va ramer
recettes de fonctionnement les c'est
pour cela qu'il fallait faire attention
pour avoir un autre document sont
insuffisants c'est pour cela qu'il
fallait se désendetter mais d'autres
collectivités qu'il faut pas qui j'étais
avant marie claire qui investissent qui
communiquent et autre evans ou ont fait
pas ça
nous ça fait plus de cinq ans qu'est ce
qu'on fait c'est un enfant on travaille
on lit sur le fond on travaille ensemble
parce que vous avez tous voté toujours à
l'unanimité
donc je suis très heureux de cet
étonnement et grâce à ces aujourd'hui on
a un moteur financement l'un des
embêtements et heureusement car sans
elle cette crise comique on à ces crises
économiques et sociales et on va pouvoir
mesurer où il faut les pragmatiques pour
arrêter la politique politicienne savent
suffit parce que véritablement entrer la
politique politicienne
on fait de la coque et on n'est pas bon
voilà ce que je voulais
dire en termes de réponse des paroles en
garde à vue ainsi va le retrouver dans
la présentation du compte l'année
dernière j'avais fait sensiblement la
barre
nous n'étions pas un autre jour
d'élection des fans mauvais procès qui
est fait sur ce sur ce sujet là sur la
question éthique que j'ai procès sur la
question la question donc nous entend
pas bien visiter pose une question sur
le rapport qui nous a besoin
d'éducateurs et celle récente annuel est
ce que j'ai présenté celles résultant la
parole pardon c'est une phrase que tu as
vu ça l'assad résultats annuels
quand je représente et ce qu'a toujours
le résultat final ensuite on cumule avec
les résultats qui remercie et donc ça
c'est le résultat cumulé reprendre mes
résultats en valeur et de présenter mais
ça c'est vraiment et collective dès
qu'on présente un résultat même si la
réponse à sa question monsieur l'image
de la parole oui le jeu moi je suis
effectivement surpris de cette réaction
mais c'est vrai qu'avec l'expérience
s'ils ne s'y attendre moi je suis je
suis surpris déjà bon recevoir des
leçons comme si on était forcément un
avis il parce que non s'exprimant dans
le budget or moi recettes l'argent et la
manière
c'est pas l'argent on est bien d'accord
mais bon on parle plus ridiculisé les
gens comme ça ensuite sur le fond noir
il me semble que j'ai parlé le
département massive de nos collectivités
européennes
je me franchement je ne vois pas à quel
moment j'ai vu parler de quelque chose à
voir avec lui je vois vraiment pas donc
jean ou plus simplement qu'il ya là tous
doivent être plus englué dans ce genre
de choses
actuellement il qu'ils soient incapables
d'imaginer qu'on puisse penser autrement
ça relève de la paranoïa politicienne je
ne suis pas les campagnes et les cours
royales premier est de nous le président
voudrait la gestion départementale et il
me semble que l'an dernier
les préoccupations qui souhaiteraient
avoir un grain mesure est de pouvoir
mesurer l'impact de nos politiques de
des montants qui sont annulés qui sont
français sur soi langlois sur les
répercussions nature décidé de proposer
quelqu'un qui est chargé de faire
banalise dans la dépression
pardon je peux on est là pour essayer
d'avancer ensemble et de faire avancer
les trottoirs et l'alsace où on sort je
vais faire ça dit signalant que cette
forte souhaite qu'on puisse avancer tous
ensemble dans ce cas pas aider à la
réparation plus sûre sur dévalue
l'assureur travaux de commission et
notamment à la commission a
régulièrement fait sur des sorties vers
l'emploi
après diverses banques s'est désolé le
diable c'est juste comme ça
donc voilà on est plutôt grand et puis
il ya effectivement le travail qu'ils
effectuent effectué au xi e sur l'impact
de nos de nos politiques sur l'emploi et
la rue qui en proportion
alors on est on est là mais vous le
savez et je pense que tout le monde le
sait on ne veut pas aller la présidente
la première pour m on est là avoir
besoin à l'entrée de cette crise
économique et sociale
vialade les marchés on a des marges dans
la mise à
d'ailleurs bien fortement augmenté ici
c'est venez nous avons inscrit 101
millions d'euros d'investissements a le
jeu ça pour rien je voudrais aussi et
moi vous rappeler d'autres conseils et
partager deux premiers plans d'urgence
dans quatre territoires solidaire à
destination de fort j'ai pas si j'ose
dire le document économique touristique
et l associatif
nous allons confirmer également jay z a
une nouvelle fois ça n'a pas été fait
forcément par toutes les collectivités
mais savait aussi court d'autres plans
belle ratio en lien direct sont déployés
aux points de bercy il faut également
avec la quantifier en fonction des bleus
voit ici la fin des recrutements
si nous allons tous les budgets et recel
c'est pour relever je me dis
solennellement d'édifier économie
solidaire alors avant le vote que je
vais devoir me sortir pourquoi questions
merci du débat pour une appartient de
mettre aux voix ce qui est à huy hà
lecture de la délibération
je donne la parole à la rapporteure la
condition des noirs
merci le conseil départemental
quoique le départ de la présidente de la
salle de l'assemblée lors du débat et du
vote approuve le rapport relatif aux
comptes administratifs 2010 9 selon les
modalités énoncées en annexe 2 de la
présente délibération
bien merci je mets au bois est ce qu'il
y a les auditions à l'adoption compagnie
style d abstention n'est pas le cas je
suppose que tout le monde est favorable
mais quand même ça me lever la main ceux
qui sont favorables y compris ceux qui
sont lizio merci de bien vouloir me
prononcer sur le monde est concentré et
présenter la dame la mission il est vous
présenter ma décision modificative fois
et marqué essentiellement par la forte
implication du département au soutenir
les acteurs locaux entreprises
associations établissements
médico-sociaux fonction des cauris moi
parce que vous tous on va peut-être
pouvoir
notre droit nous avons également
[Musique]
lors de la présentation des dialyses va
nous avions les qualités du public
il était intervenu juste après le débat
non mais c'est important de rossi
l'année parce que vous aviez entendu sa
demande
alors est-ce qu'on peut commencer
ces décisions de l'édifice et activent
le maire mois présentent un besoin de
financement c'est à dire que les
politiques ont été mis en oeuvre dans
cette crise au total 17 1 millions
savoir dans une décision difficile tous
vous avez des augmentations des ventes
mais aussi on modifie aussi rousse est
également votre recette légalement
investi pour qu'on vous présente d'abord
la section de fonctionnement en dépend
championnat je suis ça c'est le montant
choque de bandits scientifique et là je
sais pas si vous a pris plein les yeux à
nîmes poursuivez et parce que sont la
dépense supplémentaire en venir
suite à la crise que vit le département
vous savez les a ainsi prévenu prévu de
soutenir les idées pas en dégageant
200000 euros pour les aider à faire face
à leurs frais
modificative ainsi que de 48h à deux
tests sérologiques selon m
je n'ai pas vraiment également souvent à
côté des familles et il a prévu un
renforcement éducatif au sortir du
conteneur vraiment temps de deux cent
mille euros ainsi que les secours
supplémentaires en justice peut demander
[Musique]
ensuite il part aussi un surcoût
constamment rsa l'adversaire d'euros le
département comme la vie la présidente a
également créé l'association pendant mes
deux millions que vous voyez l'honneur
dans cette île sur leur résistance a été
initiée par dante s nous avons fait les
banques de fonctionnement est évidemment
investissements en fonction de l'écart
enfle hydro est également un four des
professionnels du tourisme 300 euros
pour promouvoir l'attractivité du
territoire et également une enveloppe de
350 agents départementaux sont
particulièrement mobilisés pendant la
crise et le département à acheter avec
ses partenaires des masques pour la
population pour plus de 3000 euros
ainsi présence du gène et gollum faut un
revenu de c'est pour ça que vous aviez
bien l'expulsion du buteur
concernant cette dépendance
complémentaire concernant la section
fonctionnement les recettes que vous
pouvez remarquer ici en mon regroupe
également des modifications totalement
les rues
oui mais recèle pas rebondir
sur les recettes nous avons des recettes
part supplémentaire parce que comme nous
avons acheté de masques nous avons aussi
des co financements pour acheter des
masques communauté de communes et
communautés d'agglomération
la caisse d'assurance maladie
d'alsace-moselle également l'état qui
des recettes complémentaires et je pense
que c'est un bon temps 2 ensuite sur la
section d'investissement
vous avez des dépenses d'investissement
qui son logiciel qui d'abord sur les
ventes vous allez la maison à la 34e
vous avez dimensions ne fait pas de
convergence pour plus de 7 milliards
d'euros
c'est très important la subvention par
place face à 21 euros près soutien
supplémentaire et complémentaire du
département pour les places
concernant nous avons réussi à les
traquer rapportant à l'étanchéité des
barrages routes des dépenses
représentées en plus de nombreux autres
défenseurs visualiser et bien entendu
des dépenses fonctionnement il faut
résistante parce que je vous rappelle
certes initiée par le grand test mais le
département du nord est bien investi 1,6
hors un gain de 5-0 sans résistance
voilà ses investissements vous avez
demandé défense minoré mais je ne
voulais pas d'examen parce qu'il ya des
retards
évidemment par rapport aux composantes
mais des vidéogrammes en montagne
chantier
ui ml banque d'investissement il se
reprend activement à 4,2 sur les
recettes
vous avez également d excitation ce qui
veut dire ce qui veut dire que je vais
évidemment vous proposer de valider
cette décision modificative de 17,0 et
surtour d'affecter résultats du compte
administratif
vous avez un résultat que c'est 90 90
euros
je vous propose de les affecter à à
cette décision de niche il est 17h et le
sol pour faire pousser une réserve de
fonctionnement pour faire face à la
crise économique
il succède à l'actrice de 37 1 0 mais en
même temps de réserver 27,6 millions
d'euros pour le plan d'avenir autour de
fesman voilà la composition
si le président veut qu'on pourrait pas
aller criirad ars ou demander le
remboursement
les tests qu'on a réalisé pour le compte
des services de santé était défaillante
période les jeunes d'asnières de
trésorerie et payer des centaines
d'enfants pas de santé n'appartient pas
directement département ces divers que
tout soit construit à l'arrivée ce
remboursement de ces tests ont été
réalisés alors que la danse était
défaillant dans cette période merci pour
cette édition verra les contrats par des
sous
la scène pourrait nourrir et rajouter de
l'eau sur salon faire la différence
c'est très bien de faire une proposition
pour apporter un témoignage par rapport
au fond qu'on est là qu'on a voté
récemment pour soutenir les associations
d'accession en tout cas toutes les
actions par faire dans nos compétences
obligatoires fonctionnement de toutes
les associations mais toutes satisfaites
et étant bien donc parce qu'on sait
combien il était là pour les épauler et
il ya la rallonger une subvention de
presque 10 euros par ses fonctions ce
n'est pas un vrai défi je pense donc
fort de le saluer et puis donc c'était
partenaires sur lesquels on peut compter
et ils sont su aussi qu'ils peuvent
compter sur nous voilà je voulais quand
même le dire mais aussi aurélien dit
j'aime beaucoup paris notamment une
version des droits roger en effet ce
généreux et moi aussi je pense et bons
d'achat de pas mal de nous tiens ces
jeux vous pourrez pas les collègues en
visio revoir les connecte sans
permission et en appelle toutes les
suivantes
je vois une demande de parole c'est
daniela d'un docu si on peut les avoir
en grand
[Musique]
c'est bon et pour te voir si merci
madame la présidente chers collègues
ça fait quelques temps qu'on aurait pu
dire pas mal de choses c'est un peu plus
difficile en visioconférence à distance
que si on participe d'une manière réelle
au débat tout d'abord rapidement chers
collègues
j'étais je suis d'accord avec pas mal de
propos qu'avait énuméré philippe
trimaille tout à l'heure je tiens à le
dire qui était en dehors d'un combat un
politique au local aux municipales mois
chez moi c'est réglé le problème
municipal donc voila mais néanmoins il
ya des choses qui ont été dites que je
tiens ici à dire surtout sur le
désendettement il faut pas en faire une
maladie je pense à un moment où l'argent
n'est pas tellement cher faut pas en
faire une maladie de ceux des dents les
entêtements or quelquefois je trouve que
ben voilà au département on est un peu
aux puces sur cette question ensuite sur
le sur ce qu'on vient nous montrer que
j'ai devant moi là à l'instant dans la
constitution dans l'affectation des plus
un j'espère et et ce matin madame la
présidente si je suis pas chez vous
c'est parce que justement j'avais black
soucis dans ma commune qui n'est pas
facile à gérer je vais déjà souvent dit
mais je reviens pas là dessus et est
donc quelque part moi il m'aurait paru
intéressant et important qu'on apporte
un peu de 2,2 grâce et communes qui ont
beaucoup de difficulté à travers tes de
la cinquième comme qui est menée par
notre talentueux premier vice-président
assez clair il se doit
des besoins d'argent oui j'ai besoin
d'argent la richesse des différences kg
différence et non permettez moi de dire
entre ceux qui en ont et ceux qui
tension hier soir j'ai ouvert les plis
pour agrandir notre école maternelle
600000 il me faut j'ai une belle aide de
l'état
mais je suis ric-rac j'ai parlé et hier
soir en ouvrant les plis g + 40 milles
je sais pas où les trouver je ne les ai
parlé plus quarante mille contre nez
bien ça voilà donc j'ai deux mille
habitants quand même qu'ils ont déjà 200
lits va donc voilà je sais pas que j'ai
trouvé le tracteur de la commune a cramé
hier soir j'ai dû vers l'ubp des mains
des pièces partent à déterminer s'il
vous plaît le le réparateur mady est
temps de changer
je n'ai pas les moyens voilà donc
quelques pas et me paraissait important
chers collègues d'autres choses là voilà
merci merci je reconnais que je me
permets juste dit rush pour bt collègues
ma vision entre désentettement les fans
du tout celle que vous semblez c'est
bien au contraire
vous voyez bien les actions que nous
menons présent et ce que nous allons
encore c'est de l'argent du contribuable
c'est de l'argent public
nous devons être respectueux mais nous
sommes là avant tout peut-être quotidien
au service de nos concitoyens au service
des haut rhinois et tous les plans tous
les dispositifs que nous avons mis en
place dans ce sens et notamment chers
collègues des dispositifs et qui soit
forte et là aussi je crois pas
on peut dire et sans vouloir nous se
mettre les leurs y est sûr est que si
les rend fous les nains sont très
appréciés par lui même très bien
pas d'autres prises de parole le pouvoir
tous les collègues ont visionné france à
la voile a beaucoup madame la présidente
juste peut-être deux mois je voudrais
simplement saluer effectivement cette
réserve de fonctionnement qui va être
famiz qui est destiné à faire face à la
crise je crois que c'est important
effectivement je certainement que cette
crise sera plus encore plus important ne
peut l'estimer aujourd'hui donc je crois
qu'effectivement il faut être attentive
à cette sortie de crise à l'égard de
tout le monde des plus fragiles mais
voilà tout
je crois que c'est vraiment quelque
chose qu'il faut aborder de façon
sereine et ne pas se cacher derrière son
petit doigt pour dire qu'effectivement
tout ira bien mais je crois vraiment que
cette réserve le paraît intéressante
dans ce sens là je voudrais simplement
dire qu'effectivement alors oui ce débat
sur le besoin d'autofinancement je crois
qu'il faudrait pouvoir l'heureux de
débattre au moment du budget je voudrais
simplement dire que des budgets
d'investissements importants signifie
aussi d'avoir du personnel en face qui
est capable de mettre en oeuvre ce
budget d'investissement et ça je crois
qu'il faudra qu'on y soit attentif pour
que les projets qui sont proposés
puissent être mises en oeuvre dans les
temps que nous avons choisi
donc voilà c'est c'est important que le
personnel les agents qui sont sollicités
dans différents domaines est la capacité
de réaliser ses projets peut-être en les
accompagnant différemment
qu'at on voit bien que c'est un projet
ondée fois par du mal à à sortir parce
que nous avons de nombreux projets qui
sont en cours et qu'il faudrait réussir
à peut-être à mettre en face les agents
nécessaires pour faire avancer les
projets de façon sereine
merci beaucoup si chers collègues juste
la mort par rapport à la réalisation
notre investissement je crois qu'il ait
pu dire qu'on est beau parce que ça vaut
quand même un taux de réalisation des
investissements
alors c'est exceptionnel 85 3%
ça veut dire qu'on arrive de nouveau à
sortir notamment au niveau des routes
nous avons recruté trois apprentis alors
il ya certainement encore des services
il ya une charge de travail importante
notre droit mais si les besoins en
personnels lorsqu'ils se font les
ajustements qui sont si vous le
permettez
j'ai aussi rencontré six jours scier le
directeur général de l'as d'irak et je
voudrais peut-être là je viens de
reprendre aux éléments dans steam à
quelques jours et il me disait que
qu'ils craignent évidemment à elle à
dire à sa fille marine puisque vous
aurez la vice-présidente des mois à
venir
difficile pour certaines branches et
d'entreprises industrielles alsatia mais
pour l'heure il sait ce que moi
j'entends aussi des différentes branches
professionnelles
j'ai rencontré pour l'heure les
enregistre à la dira depuis le
déconfinement une forte série de projets
d'investissements nouveaux ou
ressortent des cartons des entreprises
alsaciennes française est aussi étranger
on joue là des robes en stock
aujourd'hui près de 160 projets
d'investissements significatifs pour
4500 création d'emplois potentiels et
2007 mais bien d'euros d'investissements
matériels étaient immobiles
donc voilà être le plat parce que je
pense qu'on est tous des difficultés
mais il faut pas que désespérions en
ayant confiance en elle il m'a précisé
aussi que dans le traitement
l'adira travaille sur plusieurs projets
d'implantation de capitaux étrangers
allemands suisses danois américain et
c'est là aussi une preuve
l'attractivité de nos territoires situés
en plein coeur de l'europe au carrefour
des carrefours avec le rhin à
proximité avec l'euroairport xl fameux
un acte aussi et par les voleurs chers
collègues on va dire à travers la marque
alsace après lui aussi plusieurs actions
de communication et de travail avec les
acteurs de l'agriculture avec les
acteurs de l'agroalimentaire du tourisme
du commerce et l'attractivité l'alsace
et susciter de la consommation locale le
service
nous avons aussi l'adira d'arrêter en
synergie avec le département et je tiens
à remercier leurs équipes sur la d es
mort
ou encore pas si haute qu'il est ce
qu'il est l'adoption de mercy madonna
elle est adoptée cette fois nous sommes
au bout et des rapports de la première
commission
si le président d'a2m service présente
le rapport important
sa collègue est parmi nous des exemples
de la présidence est situé sur les
conséquences sociales précédent
[Musique]
surtout les cyprès anciennes et
représente 40 mille emplois salariés de
travailler c'est à dire ça existe ça
l'est aussi du tesla et des territoires
des seynois résistance elle se fond dans
le vide finalement les avances important
laisser l'objet de rapports de deux ans
nuit tu es le très justement fonds
d'urgence exceptionnelle en faveur de la
sau et stickers fondamentale est très
important puisqu'il était de 81,8 132
1000 euros on peut financer
gfr dans les périodes de relance on
parlait département afrique du fonds
d'urgence et c'est très important
la vocation d'aller d'entreprise les
aider à la provence et cela surtout que
j'ai une entreprise avec le respect des
protocoles sanitaires vouloir d'aidés
supplémentaires importants ou encore
fils de l'un des soutiens donc ce fonds
est le bienvenu il va participer et dans
son intervention à la reconquête de la
créativité de notre territoire et c'est
vrai que tout rythme jusqu'à présent été
une force pour notre département une
étoile à venise qui reste tout l'enjeu
de tous la patente maison notre
approbation
6 merci cher max delmond demandé la
parole monsieur également oui bonjour
bonjour tout le monde
consolante pourri il ya un aspect
économique je veux dire aux six
marqueurs territoriale est un élément de
notoriété et aussi de reconquête des
coeurs monde entier de la france vers
l'alsace
donc ne pas oublier quand on a besoin
d'aidé le tourisme aussi pour faire une
forme de marketing territorial pour
l'acheter à merci engagements sont
coprésidents parole c'est juste une
précision quant au calendrier
c'est vraiment un fonds d'urgence
puisque donc les professionnels du
tourisme faire leur demande
suite et c'est notre commission
permanente du 11 septembre qui
attribuera que max delmond cherche
encore chers collègues je vous propose
qu'on voit qui est demandé madame dhalla
à l'apparence humaine
[Musique]
donc il ya plus de paroles non je vois
autres abstentions ça n'est pas le cas
merci vous dirais que c'est réellement
attendu notre direct merci c'était le
seul rapport de la deuxième commission
compass mandat quatrième commission et
son président monsieur nicolas présentes
avant de vous présenter le rapport d'un
quatrième coach la direction de
l'autonomie qui a lui aussi travaillé
nuitées joue en afrique
je voulais également signalé la
conséquence positive des choix qui ont
été faits dans le passé sur la
numérisation nos dossiers puisque aussi
bien pour la direction l'automobile
récemment et de façon déjà ancienne de
plage grâce à la numérisation des
dossiers ont pu continuer pendant toute
la période de comptes de confinement à
instruire ces dossiers et à traiter les
demandes le fait par une personne âgée
et les personnes en situation de
handicap
malgré le travail qui passe c'est une
conséquence qui n'est pas attendue qui a
été extrêmement positive dans la vente
traitement de ces dossiers là bas de
gamme de notre déplacement à seulement
voilà pour laquelle il est important
puisqu'il s'agit des conséquences et des
clôtures de la convergence avec l'onu
par un investissement
évaluée comme vous l'avez vous fait
cadeau à la parole après avoir tant que
la situation n'est pas si nous le bétail
a lancé le détail mais je montrais la
présentation de ce rapport
reconsidération du montant financier de
l'aide financière qu'ils parlent des
travaux que ces établissements ont
réalisé sur importante qui est la mienne
lui de vouloir soutenir les
investissements réalisés mais le vent de
ces investissements des crabes et en
conséquence l'augmentation les journées
de résidence et du fait de notre
intervention un peu plus soutenue et
maintenant maintenant à la casse ça
permettra soit de pallier à ces
augmentations ou deux mois de maîtriser
le coût de réalisation est ce que je
peux demander aux collègues et ses
missions d'éteindre leurs micros ont ils
vous parlent pas
la technique de s'en charger je vous en
ai fait cher collègue dans la droite
ligne de notre plan seniors nous
poursuivons ainsi notre soutien aux
ehpad afin d'améliorer les conditions
d'accueil des résidentes des conditions
de travail aussi personnel est vrai en
détrônant aussi avoir une pensée
particulière dans mon personnel le
travail du très très très difficile
alors toute notre reconnaissance vient
de le dire monsieur le premier président
l'association être allégée d'autre part
la course aux voix qui ce qui est pour
et abstentions faire rapport adopté
gratin de la quatrième commission et
merci à vous aussi
le président actuel monsieur le premier
ministre c'est un seul rapport en éviter
ainsi des parts a causé plus de une
commutation obligatoire va falloir
relatives aux transactions immobilières
réalisées l'année précédant
communication donc soumets à votre votre
approbation ou à votre prise la lémance
et des recettes que notre proposition au
nom d'al et demi les réprouve les choses
à rajouter
la rapporteure s'il n'y a pas de
questions la parole à madame monique
martin la porte après avoir délibéré le
programme de la communication de la
présidence relatives aux transactions
réalisée non mais le rapport revoit
adoptée à présent dire soit la sixième
commission et son président michel hamy
mercredi dans le rapport pour la 6eme
plombier qu'en fermant à tj la pire des
marchés matures et dans le 20ème
anniversaire donc notre collectivité il
ya 20 ans s'est élancé dans cette
comédie concept et d'aménagement du
territoire entre l'échelon intercommunal
communales et départementales
tous les domaines de l'environnement
l'agriculture et des périssent
donc il s'agit aujourd'hui de réfléchir
on ferait de cette politique et
réfléchir à l'évolution de cette
démarche service dans que du bien commun
et surtout celle de la création de
plaine d'alsace
je rappelle tout simplement que cette
politique et que concerne de développer
un modèle plus diversifiée respectueux
de l'environnement et ce qui assure aux
agriculteurs alsaciens et ne juste
rénumération deux intérieurs au terium
temps réalisé les productions
alimentaires ait été pour sécuriser
l'accès les razzias à une alimentation
durable et de réserver les écosystèmes
alsatia et de la richesse et du baron
pierre de faire connaître et fédérés par
une politique de communication est
politique et donc de réfléchir également
à ses rivaux à une démarche destinée à
lutter contre les îlots de chaleur en
zone
pour les grandes lignes donc si celui ci
ces lignes de deux politiques qui ont
été discutés pas plus tard que hier avec
les collectes il concédé par ou à vous
dire galère merci merci madame à
président donc je vous propose après en
avoir délibéré d'approuver le rapport
relatif à la stratégie d'avenir pour la
démarche chère plan selon les modalités
énoncées en annexe à de la présente
délibération
le deuxième rapport
c'est une décision modificative numéro
un le budget de la régie des bâtons tas
de production d'énergie électrique donc
dépenses ce budget à 1 million 400 500 9
974 euros 26 ans il le sera plus
sécuritaire a million 200 à 1000 euros
soit une augmentation de plus de 139
1974 euros
il s'agit en fait de cette chanson-là du
national en imprévus longueur bpe de 800
et 1500 euros la reprise de l'excédent
cumulé de 9 semaines c'est fini 97 euros
l'affectation de l'excédent
investissements donc 120000 388 euros en
révision de la constitution d'une
installation production d'énergie
hydroélectrique sur le barrage de prudes
inspection de 50000 euros
aude et aromates d'or des installations
photovoltaïques du collège d'isaac et
instructeur de 50 euros ou
l'installation sur le barrage
le truc voilà en résumé je passais pas
de modification merci beaucoup mais
maintenant je vais là donc je je vous
invite à prouver leur
par relatifs à la décision modificative
numéro 1 du budget de la régie
départementale de production d'énergie
électrique selon les modalités
présentées en annexe 1 si le rapport on
vous à votre compte
merci beaucoup merci messieurs le fait
que mon passé au rapport de la 10ème
édition
sa présidente madame madame la
présidente
donc ça craque pas dans quelle
convention
la première concerne la ville en santé
je n'ai pas lorsqu'un ancien de l'état
elles confirment leur conseil de famille
d'adoption
plus grave ils fassent des pierres qui
peut aboutir au jugement d'adoption
processus doit permettre d'autres
présentant des nouvelles figures et de
reconnaître et quand les candidats à la
location comme pas dire cette phrase un
accompagnement et fait parler sa
protection d'enfance limitée de sa vie
d'antan en collaboration avec l'enfant
de nos rangs sous la centralité des
éditeurs dans l'objectif se définit les
droits et obligations ainsi qu'aux les
responsabilités du fondateur
il vous est proposé d'approuver une
convention de placement qui a conclu
avec les candidats à la gauche et ce
n'est pas le cas de la démission après
en avoir déjà approuvé le rapport
relative ascension au classement mais
d'adoption selon les modalités énoncées
en annexe à la présente circulaire
conjointe de foudre abstention rapport à
leur mercie ceux qui conscients tippl
deux parties
rien pour l'organisation d'une action
collective de soutien à la parentalité
il se raconte ariane organismes
partenaires il services de la protection
maternelle et infantile et la cigale
après en avoir délibéré de partenariat
l'organisation d'actions collectives de
soutien parental
selon les modalités aussi on a des stats
la présente délibération contre
abstention record
merci voyons alors qu'un rapport
reconduire comme chaque année
affectation des résultats je te dis
vivement de l'accepter le mans france
la proposition d'affectation des rues de
la cité de l'enfance elle
le budget de fonctionnement de la cité
de l'enfance est financé par le conseil
départemental
les compositions de l'affectation des
résultats même informé 30 et les
évolutions futures de la dotation des
parties concernant l'investissement le
sol d'un épuisant fait l'objet d'un
rapport au budget d'investissement de la
maison utilisant comme je l'aï dit
classique de clôture de l'exercice
comptable de parole après avoir délibéré
je vous propose approuvé le rapport
relative à l'affectation des résultats
de l'exercice 2010 à la cité de
l'enfance
selon les modalités initiales avec
strass présenter libération si bonne
contre abstentions merci la vie dans le
4 e mandat
[Musique]
le présent rapport a pour objet
d'approuver et contention dit un autre
visant l'accès aux réseaux sociaux et
notamment m21 du logiciel sur un fond
social du logement pour leur permettre
dans l'enregistrement direct avec
demande est à l'axé dépôt de garantie
des loyers etc
au titre du fonds social de logements
cette convention d'un phare des
incidences bien sûr financière pour le
département et pour le compte du fonds
social au logement mais il permettra
bien sûr de réduire les délais de
diffusion d'attribution etc à l'accès au
parc social
deux ans après en avoir délibéré je vous
propose d'approuver le rapport relatif à
la mise à disposition sur msn ou
ailleurs ce soit le traitement lui
demandait pour levante pour le mouvement
soit les vaisselles selon modalités nous
y amène annexes de la présente
délibération
si votre contre abstention rapport
adopté et le dernier lequel les rapports
servent à nouveau et d'intéressant dans
le département en bonne chose bien sûr
les départements tous les ans les gens
notamment étudiants sein de ses services
durant les mois d'été en raison des
cinqueterre ce dispositif n'est pas
complet ce sens de l'humain hassen el
demain qu'à lire ce coup de pouce aux
jeunes mariés et de surcroît de soutenir
les associations et les causes et ses
ailières recruter un jeune pendant un
mois à la charge du département dans un
autre dispositif gagnant même en son
temps qui sont concernées elles seront
annoncées à l'issue d'élections honnêtes
alimentaire aide et de l'éducation
l'environnement et pour des jeunes de 18
à 25 ans pour un coût de 200 euros
soixante deux associations citées penser
5 dans le champ de l'insertion et celle
dans le champ de l'éducation
environnementale et 65 postes prévues
pour la simple c'est vrai que nous
sommes très investis dans dans la
jeunesse c'est une volonté politique de
notre dans cette crise qui a beaucoup
affecté
les jeunes aussi ont leur venaient à la
femme financier par roche
c'est un dossier aux associations pour
un apport de sensibiliser les jeunes à
la fin de l'été merci de préciser
comment la notion de danger aussi pour
adapter les rapports de la commission
madame la présidente est juste un point
avant de revenir aux rapports madame la
présidente
permettez moi de m'associer à tous les
remerciements qui vous ont été attribués
en début de séance et je voudrais ça
le mans rajouter un de ses remerciements
qui n'a pas été évoqué c'est aussi vous
remercier pour la tension que vous avez
porté à vos collègues à vos collègues du
département et j'en veux comme exemple
la vitesse à laquelle vous aviez répondu
à un sms où j'avais des choses
importantes à vous dire je n'ai même
plus je n'ai même pas plus chers
collègues poser mon téléphone que
j'avais déjà un coup de fil voilà non
mais s'était appréciée chez brigitte
vraiment et je crois qu'il faut le dire
tu as une attention pour tous les haut
rhinois belle attention pour nous tous
par rapport à tout ce qui se passe je
souhaitais le dire alors j'en viens au
rapport
ce n'est pas un rapport c'est une
communication sur le rapport
d'observations qu'a fait la chambre
régionale des comptes sur les comptes de
l'eurodistrict trinational à bâle cela
concerne la période de 2015 à 2018
ce rapport ne constate aucun manquement
je crois que c'est important de le dire
il souligner le très bon niveau
d'activité de le tbc son rôle dans la
recherche des fonds européens avec un
effet de levier
et bien sûr il marque aussi que le
fonctionnement de l'été b est très
complexe puisque nous sommes là dans
trois pays c'est encore plus complexe
que quand on est un deux et que le la
cour des comptes aux demandes qu'il y a
une vision un peu plus globale et
processus budgétaire qui mériterait
d'être simplifier et clarifier
voilà mais néanmoins les membres sont
informés et tout se passe au mieux dans
la mesure où on travaille ensemble et on
essaye de construire quelque chose s'il
bouge à coller des principaux mais je
crois que quand on a parlé de chaîne de
solidarité pendant la crise et un
sélectionneur et existait aussi entre
nous et je tenais à le signer
est ce qu'il ya des questions ça n'est
pas le cas je passe la parole
je propose de donner à la présidente la
communication relative aux observations
de la chambre portant examens légaux
2015 à 2018
l'eurodistrict la nakba merci à vous est
ce qu'il ya des vocaux abstention très
fort heureusement si fort à l'écouter
dans le domaine transfrontalier
si important d'être à présent la
dernière commission la 12e avec son
président monsieur merci la fédé rapport
à vous présenter la saignée
l'observation de marie-france mal alors
des collections réunies ne l'est pas de
d2 et non wintzenheim
nous avons fait la corruption dans le
pays
je confirme et messieurs je passe la
parole à madame rapport merci on peut
conseil départemental
après en avoir délibéré adopte le
procès-verbal de la séance plénière par
visioconférence du conseil départemental
du vendredi 24 avril et 1020 abstention
ça me va
concert vous plaidez je suis en oeuvre
avant le 12 janvier
a profité pour remercier l'ensemble des
agents utilisent à sion pendant la crise
à l'assistant personnel de la direction
de l'immobilier est la nôtre à nous je
partirai en ciel aux agents étaient en
télétravail chez eux à la maison mais il
a aussi remercié ces fachos notre dgs
l'ensemble des électrices de directeur
s'est organisée au lieu de ressources
humaines mais reste ainsi facebook mais
on sa collectivité
alors lorsqu'ils commencèrent le rapport
ainsi que puisque pour valider la
politique
les agents actuels et conversion au sein
d'à côté et de présenter les avancées
aux à la collectivité notamment
l'attribution de logements de fonction
est le véhicule le bronze
merci monsieur le rapporteur
le conseil départemental après en avoir
délibéré approuve le rapport relatif aux
ressources humaines selon les modalités
énoncées en annexe à de la présente
délibération abstentions le rapport est
méritée et le dernier roi donc le
dernier rapport sur le rapport
d'activité nos miss lens
ce rapport présente l'ensemble des
voyages qui avaient été mobilisés
nombreuses opérations réalisées par le
département du rhône alpes des 19
le gala de ces différences les
rapidement document linus calais a cité
la finance des missions de la
collectivité et se décline à travers le
savez que principalement thématique
d'interactivité d'aménagement des
territoires des territoires et des
affiches de crue lassonde inc
et bien sûr l'éducation la culture le
sport et l'administration fédérale et
les ressources
il y à mettre en exergue l'exemple des
nombreuses réalisations les goûts
l'endiguement des bulles qui posé par
l'assemblée des bas et puis donc vous
est proposée le pouvoir des résidants de
cette communication et le jura
si monsieur le président ces questions
car je voudrais remercier à mon tour
bons rapports d'activité et donc combien
[Musique]
le conseil départemental en avoir
délibéré d'aunac au président la
communication relative au rapport
d'activité et services de l'année 2009
participation 10 passion est
particulièrement active aujourd'hui je
me permets de vous rappeler mes options
date cet après midi déjà réunion de la
cinquième commission
le 3 juillet nous aurons à 8h30 une
commission permanente
il y avait 10h15 une séance publique et
le préfet nous rejoindra lors de cette
séance publique pour la présentation du
rapport est adopté
merci je me souhaite encore que journée
merci aux campagnards à notre séance la
séance sera de nouveau lancé sur les
réseaux ajouté prochain
bonne journée à tous mais elle est en or
massif
à commencer par quoi